all right we already have uh questions
lined up for the ama so we may as well
get started
um beautiful day here in milwaukee cold
but we've got the windows open so you're
gonna hear a little bit of street noise
and
wind from the eighth floor up
uh and the light will be changing from
time to time i imagine as well
so let me start with the first questions
that i actually have here
i'll mention too that if you put in
questions ahead of time
like you know hours ahead of time
youtube somehow doesn't transfer them
here
so um
it's kind of a waste of time to find
them up too
too far in advance
so from dammit albert i get the
impression many thinkers for example
philip a foot tend to dismiss
utilitarianism as almost childish or
naive
even as they treat it as a sort of
modality or trait of their own ethical
systems why is that the case that's a
good question
i don't know enough about foot per se in
her various writings she's only
she's somebody who i've only read in in
parts
to say whether she thinks that
utilitarianism is
in fact something
naive or childish
that doesn't doesn't really ring true to
the things that i remember reading from
her
um
but i think there are a lot of people
who do treat utilitarianism
as if it's just kind of a silly doctrine
um and very often the arguments that
they provide against it like oh it's
just too difficult to calculate you know
if they'd actually read their their mill
or bentham or or sidrwick or even you
know contemporary utilitarians like
singer they'd see them addressing that
very early on saying you don't have to
calculate everything you do have to make
some effort to try to
you know come up with you know some
weighing of harms and benefits or
happiness and misery or however you're
going to put it
um i think a lot of people view
utilitarianism
as
you know
a bad ethical theory and and this
usually has less to do with
utilitarianism as such
in its you know well-developed and
articulated forms and probably more to
do with the psychology or the poor
education of those people
you know utilitarianism is not the the
enemy robert audi
um actually has a really great article
that i have my business ethics majors
read
where he's talking about cost benefit
analysis and showing how even a
conscient or virtue ethicist ought to be
doing some cost benefit analyses
in in some certain you know situations
and so one of the key ideas that's often
associated with utilitarianism turns out
to be useful in other ways
you know i'll mention too that this has
come up interestingly in another
forum
when it comes to stoicism right
stoic ethics are often interpreted as
being straight virtue ethics or or
deontological in some respect and not
utilitarian
but you know if you actually read and
think about what prudence requires of
you sometimes it requires
assessing benefits and harms and trying
to maximize the benefit and trying to
reduce the uh
the harm right so
you know um you're not going to get away
from it all together that doesn't mean
you necessarily have to be like a total
utilitarian
and buy into utilitarianism right
all right let's take the next one uh
james does hobbes
uh really have a pessimistic view of
human nature he seems to pin our
pessimism as a result of the state of
nature rather than human nature as such
instead our behavior depends on context
well i mean the state of nature
is
human beings in a state of nature where
human nature would be what it is so yes
hobbes is pretty pessimistic about human
nature you know he says things like
um you know agreements without the sword
are null and void
he actually goes so far as to say that
within the state of nature everything's
allowed
and he thinks that there's a really
grave danger of us breaking down into
that
i don't know why anyone would want to
not read hobbs as
pessimistic about human nature
outside of civil society given that he's
so clear about this
um
[Music]
but you know hobbs is also optimistic in
a way he thinks that there's there's a
possibility of us that's why he writes
leviathan and his other works there's a
possibility of us
getting out of this and cementing a
a
way of living together
that would prevent there being civil
wars and factions and all of this you
know um
you know sort of
subterranean or some you know subversive
uh struggle going on
in terms of our
our moral life and and you know
political jocking and stuff like that
now
most of us don't find his solution
particularly
congenial right uh a sovereign who's
invested with all power and who has you
know
he lays them out actually is the chapter
17 the rights of sovereigns um he lays
them out and and a lot of these rights
are not
you know they're not particularly great
i would say um
so that's probably enough about hobbs uh
galen do you like iris murdoch either as
a novelist or a philosopher and virtue
ethicist
yeah i read iris murdoch originally as a
novelist i i got a hold of her novel and
it's a big thick one i've got it around
my place somewhere
the philosopher's apprentice i think
it's called
and it's uh
it's quite good um i enjoy reading her
stuff then i went on to read um quite a
few of her other
works as well
um i haven't read an awful lot of her
philosophy i'm still
you know reading around in her gifford
lectures
but i but i like what i'm getting um
she's very smart
and she has a lot of interesting things
to say
so i'm you know
um pretty happy with what i what i am
reading in her stuff so
you know i'm
yeah i'm a fan you could say right
um
and uh
yeah i mean what else is there to
to say about that um that's probably
probably enough right
um
what's the next one uh made of clay very
easy one to answer how are you doing
today i'm doing okay um i made it back
to the gym twice this last week
after not being there for about i think
about three weeks due to all the
planning going into stoichon and being
ill off and on and having you know being
stuck with a lot of class work and a lot
of client work
um i just wasn't making it in and
you know when you've got a 50 year old
body and you go back to the gym again
and you hit the weights as hard as you
did three weeks before
you feel it
so i'm still a little bit sore my last
workout was thursday it's you know
saturday morning i'm still sore in some
parts but getting you know getting
better and hopefully this coming week i
will be able to get in you know get back
to my three weight circuits workouts a
week
um my oldest daughter
is uh in a musical at uw-milwaukee that
i'm going to be going to my wife won't
be able to make it because she has
another event but my
mother-in-law and my
my dad are going to be able to come to
it so that should be a lot of fun that's
something i'm looking forward to
classes are going pretty well you know
my students are really enjoying the
earth c class
and my ethics for artists and designers
and business ethics classes are doing
pretty good and stoicon is behind us so
that's that's a a nice thing as well
uh lyndon is it fair to see nietzsche as
a sort of historicized utilitarian he
thinks moral sentiments have emerged
from a calculus of benefit and penalty
pleasure and displeasure
i i'd say no
because
he doesn't see
he doesn't see them as emerging just
from that right there's other
important aspects as well
as a matter of fact nietzsche's
well somebody getting in in trouble out
there i would say nietzsche's um
analyses of the origins of moral
concepts and their transformation
it's complex you know
so it's not just coming from only one
thing if you look at his discussion of
punishment in
genealogy of morals this is a great
example he says you know punishment may
have emerged originally from the
creditor debt of their relationship but
there's all these other things going on
in it at the same time
and so
i would i would always with somebody
like nietzsche i would avoid
trying to
construe his point of view in in a this
is the the key to it certain way
um
here's an interesting question from josh
was there ever an experience that put
you off philosophy
so it depends on how we want to talk
about experience
and what we mean by philosophy if we're
if we're talking about like
particular
schools or
you know
ways of doing philosophy or certain
areas yeah i think
and it's usually been like a personal
experience with somebody who is a prick
um somebody who is who is entitled
and
um
you know you you met him and you're like
wow people who do that kind of
philosophy
i guess they're mostly pricks um
i will say that lebanosians
in the 90s were kind of that way because
they're all about oh you know the face
of the other and we're all hypocrites
and doing philosophy and then you talk
to them
and um
you get the idea that
these are you know these are people who
talk nice but they're not really nice
people
and when you get close to them you find
out that they don't often practice what
they they preach but that doesn't have
to turn you off of levinas per se right
that turns you off of lavanasians or
but you know i will say this
i went through a kind of crisis
of what would you call it a crisis of
feeling
wondering why the hell i was doing
philosophy and
i actually had an instructor who's not a
philosophy instructor but a classics
professor
who um and some of you i think have
heard this story before who said
something really helpful to me his name
is rick williams
and i think he's long since retired he
was an older guy when i knew him cool
older guy um
and i was thinking well why am i
studying all this stuff
you know because at that time i really
was you know uh
hitting the ground hard we had a
difficult um
set of prelims that you had to read for
and i was going way beyond that and i
was like why am i doing all this is it
just to like i'm not gonna i'm probably
not gonna like come up with some
original system of my own which people
sometimes ask about you know both in
terms of like when are you going to come
out of your system dr sadler and the
answer is probably never or that they
they're coming out and they're like how
am i going to derive an original system
of philosophy the answer is you're
probably not
um so there's that that side over there
if i'm gonna do like original work you
know what's it when's it gonna happen
what's it gonna be
and then if you do it who's gonna read
it you know uh it might fall as hume
humes treatise did still born from the
press
or if you're just replicating other
people's stuff and just you know
teaching it over and over again what
good is that i mean you're just like
letting somebody colonize your brain for
a while or parasitize it and then
producing more of that
and when i looked at it that way then of
course that's going to make you kind of
despairing and then if you realize that
that's not what's really going on you
don't have to produce something original
and you're not just
copying
and engaging in mimesis and
interpretation and hermeneutics
then you start to feel better about that
um but rick williams said to me at one
point in time
he said listen i am warming myself by a
fire
and that fire has been kept going for a
couple thousand years now
and
my only job is to keep the fire going in
case somebody else wants to sit next to
it if nobody does
and the fire dies with me that's fine
you know i did my job
but i see some value here in sitting by
the fire and feeding in a log every once
in a while and shooting the [ __ ] with
the people sitting next to me and
talking about things that we think
matter
so that's what i'm gonna do and you can
decide you know young greg
uh if if you wanna sit by that fire or
you wanna go uh do something else you
know
um that's up to you i'm i'm i'm gonna be
here and you can hang out with me if you
want to so that was
that was uh
an experience that that helped me get
back into philosophy
uh reuben can we say that the highest
maxim is living per se and everything
else is just a means to that i mean you
can say anything you like but that
sounds like kind of a boring
philosophy and pretty reductive and
leaves out almost everything else that's
interesting and
doesn't jibe with you know
the classical distinction between zane
living and out so oozing living well
so central to philosophy
um i mean anybody can start from
whatever starting points they want to
and see where that gets them then i
would say go ahead and try it see where
that gets you
further wrote
would it be safe to say sir in
kierkegaard has had some influence on
your new book reason fulfilled by
revelation
so it's not a new book came out in 2011
um and
it's not a my book per se i'm you know
you you probably want to read the book
or at least watch some of the
live readings before asking about it it
is a book of translations from the 1930s
christian philosophy debate
i wrote a historical introduction to it
was that historical introduction
influenced by sir kierkegaard no because
kierkegaard is is not um i mean nobody's
really an influence on writing an
introduction
and was kierkegaard influential on any
of the people in the debates yeah sure i
mean uh gabriel marcel mentions him at
one point but there's not a lot of
people in france reading kierkegaard at
that time
that's a little bit later on um
you know as the translations are rolling
out marcel actually writes about that
about those translations
um
and you know there wasn't a vast
influence of kierkegaard i would say on
mostly
catholic or reformed christians
um who were engaged in the the debates
at that time so no kierkegaard doesn't
have a big influence that said i
actually wrote i i wrote and presented a
paper at the atms real song society
about seven years ago six years ago
looking at kierkegaard through the lens
of the christian philosophy debates so
um but no he doesn't have a big
influence
manveer says can you give some advice to
someone who wants a studying wants to
start studying philosophy seriously yeah
start i mean there's
start uh
stick with it persevere
first time around you read a book you're
not going to get everything out of it
you can't master philosophical works
um i mean i have all all those
self-directed study videos
um that you can you can watch that that
will you know help when you want to
study plato you can check that out you
want to study
and some you want to study you know the
stoics those those could be helpful but
i mean a lot of it is just like actually
doing it you know and sticking with it
despite the fact that
unlike a lot of other disciplines
you're probably going to be really
confused in studying it at first
so
even says uh saw your twitter you're
teaching a course on existentialist
literature
would you mind sharing some of the
fiction works on the reading list so
that's next semester that's my my class
that that'll be my
third or fourth time teaching it for
milwaukee institute of art and design i
think the fourth time around teaching it
and i've taught it before in other
places
so yeah uh literature um
[Music]
i mean if you consider the spoke
zarathustra literature
we're reading uh the first the first
book of that
we read dostoyevsky's notes from the
underground
and um the rebellion and grand
inquisitor chapter from brothers
caramazoff of dostoyevsky
we read rilka's letters to a young poet
and some of rilke's poetry
um
what else kafka you know we read
in the penal colony and uh
the metamorphosis and i recommend some
some i'll talk about recommended
literature in just a bit because there's
like required and then there's
recommended stuff
uh who else um
we read uh
camus the stranger
and
um
[Music]
i'm trying to remember what we have from
from
um
[Music]
you know actually i think that's on the
recommended reading stuff so let me let
me talk about that real briefly so
um i mentioned
we have camus the stranger we also have
simone de bevars the hungry mouths which
is a great play
for kafka i recommend them also reading
the trial
for sart
the wall
you know that that play and then uh
nausea
um
gabriel marcel a broken world
you know that that play by him
i know i'm leaving somebody out
um
for una muno this time around i'm
actually going to recommend they read
fog because it's a good novel
but i'm not going to require that they
read it instead it's you know we're just
reading parts of uh tragic point of view
um
i kind of think that's it
but i might be blanking on some so
anyway um
oop a lot of just skipped up a lot
there's a lot of questions here let me
see what we have next um
lyndon asks is it difficult after
reading a crab like manifold like a
stalty figure like hegel
moving to a narrower more purist or
analytic or reductionist thinker
not not for me um in part because i
don't have trouble moving from one
thinker to the next to the next but i
mean i've been in a situation where
i need to be able to shift gears
pretty quickly most of my career
especially teaching right teaching as
many classes as i do
like i might have you know class after
class after class during a day where
first i'm teaching jon stewart mill and
then suddenly i'm teaching
nietzsche and then suddenly i'm going
all the way back to aristotle or you
know pick whatever else right so you
just kind of kind of roll with that
but it might be difficult for some
people you know maybe they have to like
readjust their their head and how they
read
mark says i just want to congratulate me
and everyone involved for a great
stoiccon last weekend really enjoyed it
how have you been keeping
uh well yeah so stoicon was a lot of
work um and i'm glad it went off as well
as it did there were a few technical
difficulties towards the end that some
may may uh have not noticed or did
notice we actually had the
the main guy behind the scenes phil
get booted out of zoom
as the host
and then andy stepped in as the host and
then her zoom froze right and so she's
like texting me saying zoom froze how
are we gonna bring up our speaker you
know this is for the plenary session so
it couldn't have happened at a worse
time but it all sorted itself out and it
was a lot of fun
um the speakers everybody enjoyed
themselves most of them stuck around for
the entire time
like duff lambro said
that she was glued to the screen
the entire time which is which is really
cool to hear
um
and it looked like you know we had just
as many people attend as last year
um
and it you know it was it was very
inclusive which we wanted to do as well
so it was it was a it was a great time
and i'm guessing we'll probably get
asked to do it again
next year um but we'll we'll see it's
that's up to the modern stoicism team
um
see just wanted to know your thoughts on
heidegger calling language and
experience and the difference with er
foreign and air laban
so i mean heidegger calls language a lot
of different things right the house of
being you know we're all familiar with
that one
uh one of the equi-primordials languages
rada you know along with
mood
throneness and pre-understanding
so language is not language is not one
single thing
that heidiger calls it it's all of these
things at once
but language also is an experience
sometimes more than others um you know
think about when you're reading
or hearing recited poetry
and it could be like in the framework of
a song
um you know think about ronnie james
dio's rainbow in the dark you know if
you've never heard that classic metal
song
it is uh amazing poetry
because ronnie james dio was an amazing
lyricist
obviously having you know the musicians
behind him
helps as well but you can just recite it
as poetry
and you are you are experiencing
something
you know it also reminds me of something
that ursula k le guin uh
wrote about that i talked about recently
in a sadly short podcast episode
um
she was talking about the the advice
right what you know
and
she said you know i would write stuff
about dragons and you know sci-fi things
and then people would say write what you
know you've not experienced that sort of
thing and she'd say
well [ __ ] i know that stuff i've
you know
who who if anybody would know about the
dragons in earth seeing if not me you
know it's my it's my world right
and so there's there's a lot of things
that we
have experience of but we don't have
experience like you know the experience
of me
biting this pen you know
which you don't have anyway you just see
me doing it and you kind of imagine it
so there's lots of things that we can
experience and put into language and
then there's a lot of things that we can
experience through language i was just
before this
recording videos uh for my ursula k le
green earth c class and we're on to the
novel to hanu
and i was you know reading i don't know
maybe for the 40th time
um
the mage ogn dying and tahana or antenna
with her with him
as he's dying
and
you know these are
these are fictional characters
but i'm there in the forest
glen as he leans his back up against the
beech tree and says the last things that
he has to say
to this woman
who
was his
adopted daughter for a while and i'm and
i'm still even recalling that even not
reading it the books upstairs
i still feel the
the sadness and grief from it so
we experienced so much through uh
language and heidegger was hip to that
you know
um
[Music]
all right made of clay did deluge
romanticize psychosis i know they are
critical of the edible structure and
psychoanalysis i was speaking to someone
who says that the therapist has the same
function as the police um i mean if you
if if you think the therapist has the
same function as the police
then
either you got the therapist wrong or
the police wrong or you got a really
weird therapeutic situation
so
that sort of that sort of hyperbolic
identification that should put you on
your guard
um did the lose
romanticize psychosis yes
he did that's not to say that we should
throw out everything that he says about
it but
i think that people like to lose and and
qatari
and foucault and that whole generation
are really best understood
within a particular context in which the
psychotherapeutic establishment was
pretty rigid you know
were they all edipolizing people no
because i mean freud himself says the
oedipus complex is something you're
supposed to get past it's not something
that you constantly talk about and
nobody does all the time in therapy
except in cartoons you know where uh
we're talking about caricatures
um
i mean duluz was prone like a lot of
people in his generation it's kind of a
new romanticism in some respects except
rejecting their the essentialism of
romanticism uh i think you know duluz is
somebody we can learn some things from
but some of frankly some of the stuff
that he talks about is
um
[Music]
just you know it's essentially like a
kind of poetry
uh and when you think through the
implications of it
it's um
you know it's either nonsensical or it's
it's very idiosyncratic
or it's um kind of silly you know
um but there's also some some things
that he has to say that are quite
brilliant so
yeah
all right um
john holloway do i think there's any
prerequisite before diving into
epictetus to get a better understanding
of him for example plato or aristotle's
works on ethics no not at all i mean
plato and aristotle aren't being
referenced by epictetus
so and and you should never like hold
yourself back and say oh i've got to
read this person before i read this
person you're not going to break your
brain if you read somebody who's
difficult
and then you have to go back and read
them again jump right in you know uh
when it comes to epictetus you know i
mean if you wanted to read some other
stoic stuff before him read seneca right
epictetus is not a platonist he's not an
aristotelian
i mean if you're going to read
simplicius who is commenting on
epictetus's
um and caridian and and simplicius is a
neoplatonist it couldn't hurt to know
something about plato before reading
some plikia so you can be like oh yeah i
see where he's going with this
but you'd probably actually be better
off reading instead of reading plato for
that reading some middle platonists you
know
um
but no epictetus is is uh you know
he's a standalone you can read him uh
just by himself
right
um
all right bruno ah nice to see you bruno
have i read any brazilian philosophers
if so who and what did you think of him
or her the only one that i've actually
read
as far as i know is uh freeri's
pedagogy of the oppressed
which you know great book in the
philosophy of education i haven't really
read any other
brazilian philosophers unless i've read
some like when i was doing secondary lit
review stuff
because i can puzzle my way through
academic portuguese
as they can through academic spanish and
italian because you know you know like
the the pronoun structure and not the
pro the um
what a prepositional structure and a lot
of the words are cognates and stuff like
that but it's very difficult for me to
do that um
i probably should take a look at what's
going on
in brazil i've you know i've met
brazilian
philosophers for example here in
milwaukee
some often we get some coming to the
aristotle and aristotelian
uh tradition conference at marquette um
that used to be held every year before
kovid and you know you chat with them
and they tell you about what's going on
in brazil
[Music]
so that would be kind of interesting
[Music]
i mean
i guess you could say since i've read a
few things by aldo dinucci who is a
brazilian philosopher who presented at
stoicon who writes about stoicism i i
guess you could say i've read him
um but i've only read a little bit of
his work so
all right uh diogenes the cynic any
opinions on what is happening with
kathleen stock i'm only curious what you
think because she was my lecturer and
now on leave at least till the end of
the term
oh i you know you you know the
expression [ __ ] around and find out i
think she's finding out um i think she's
whining a lot about
you know
all the stuff that's happening to her
and blowing quite a few things out of
proportion and i think she
on some level
my impression is she's um
engineered as much as possible a martyr
perspective um
frankly i don't really give a [ __ ] about
tenured professors who run into problems
because there are so few of them and
none of them care about the non-tenured
well some do but very few do much about
it so
you know she's she's a cause celeb and
some of my some of my colleagues um who
are all you know uh tenured professors
themselves are like oh academic freedom
this is a bad sign and stuff like that
um
i don't really care about about what
happens with kathleen stock you know
[Music]
i think that that uh
a lot of the gender critical stuff is is
really quite silly nonsense and you know
pearl clutching
um and i think we'll see that you know
sort itself out about 20 years from now
in ways similar to what has happened in
terms of um
[Music]
you know other other
marginalized minorities so
um i mean here's the thing if you give a
[ __ ] about kathleen stock and protecting
her academic freedom
i want to see you out there protecting
the academic freedom
of five people who you don't know
and who
are much more in much more precarious
positions because they don't have tenure
and maybe are going from contract to
contract as full-time people or adjuncts
and if you're not doing that then i kind
of think you're full of [ __ ] you know
um so that that's it
uh
adornos says i'm a simple man i ask a
simple question
when sandler meme review again um
yeah that's a good that's a good
question i mean i think i will probably
do something with the evil sadler meme
right i might do something with the
the uh all the evil other things it
started with evil aristotle you know
vice ethics and now we've got eagle evil
hegel and evil socrates and eagle
schopenhauer and evil uh all sorts of
other things i might put one of those
together
um floyd asks are you a fan of simone
vay's works what do you make of her life
as a kind of living contradiction drawn
to the sacraments refusing to get
baptized pacifists yet fighting in the
war for me she's a marginal figure
i have some friends who are really into
her but i've i've never found myself
particularly drawn
to her stuff um
living a life
you know uh is is quite interesting
because we do work our contradictions
out and she's she's not just a
contradiction for herself she's a
contradiction for
others and kind of a sign for others but
i gotta say i just i never
i've made a couple stabs at reading her
stuff and i've just never really gotten
into it
um
mark moore's asks what do you think
about massimo joining me in becoming a
cicerone eclectic
has he said he's a cicerone eclectic i i
don't know that he's come out and said
that i know that he's he was doing the
stoicism thing and he still is doing the
stoicism thing
um but he said well you know my
philosophy as a way of life is is a bit
broader
and i suppose i should i should chat
with him about that uh andy and i my
wife and i are going on massimo's um
podcast pretty soon
in november to talk about stoicism and
marriage and maybe it'll come up there
but i should just probably have a chit
chat with him anyway
it's about time i start um
you know i used to have that like sit
down with people
ideas or conversations that matter
interview thing and i've been thinking i
should i should start doing that again
but with zoom stuff because you know
we're
we're past the the time of
you know
adjusting to covid
like almost two years into it
um
i should i should resuscitate that and
he should be one of the people i should
talk about so maybe maybe i'll do that
that's that's a great idea
caesar says how should one go about
figuring what they want can reason or
philosophy answer this
uh
i mean you can answer that by by asking
yourself what you want i don't know that
reason or philosophy can tell you what
you actually
want that strikes me as something where
you gotta get some personal input right
reason or philosophy can help you
clarify it but you have to have the
wants
to begin with and it might help you like
figure out you say oh i want money and
then he said well why do you want money
right we can go through this whole chain
well i really want to be able to leave a
legacy for my kids i want to buy this
you know place that we can all gather
together you know well that philosophy
can help you clarify that but it's not
philosophy that's unique in that right
um
all right
here's another one from floyd mayweather
you you engage with the work of
jean-yves lacoste thoughts on the french
theological turn on phenomenology in
general i i haven't read lacoste i would
say that so i you know i was in grad
school when this supposed french turn to
phenomena
french phenomenology turned to theology
was was taking place and i think it's
[ __ ] because there was always a
strong
presence in french phenomenology of
interest in religion uh you could talk
about famous figures like levinas right
who's who's uh jewish um but you can
also talk about jean aaring you know
you can talk about paul recur it's not a
new thing it was a new thing
for
certain french intellectuals and certain
americans who were fattishly following
them to say look michelle henry and
jean-luc mario french phenomenological
turn to theology and you know if you've
read your if you're widely read you kind
of roll your eyes and you're like
come on
these guys you know themselves admit
that they're following
in the footsteps of people you know um
mario who i've met you know he knew
blondel's work uh you know he knows
raccoor's work
uh he's not doing something that's a
radical turn i think that was more of a
gimmick than anything else
um
even says in general do you have any
tips for helping one improve one's
faculty of abstraction or abstract
reasoning
um yeah i mean platonic dialectic could
do it according to the platonists
studying studying logic and not just
doing formal logic but you know reading
reading works about logic would probably
help you you know logicians reflecting
on the nature of logic whether they be
you know um
copy and some of his works not the
textbooks but his other works that could
be helpful you know
kelly says i've been reading aleister
mcintyre lately i'm confused about the
communitarianism he proposes maybe he
doesn't even propose that i was excited
when i saw this morning you have videos
about him yeah alistair mcintyre doesn't
use the term communitarianism right it
talks about communities of inquiry
other people have tried to suck him into
the communitarianism thing
um
read the mcintyre and don't pay that
much attention to what other people say
about mcintyre just stick with the
mcintyre
and see where he's going you know read
after virtue and then follow it up with
the next three books in in the
quadrilogy
and then after you're done with that
then then you can you know say oh okay
i like this part i don't like this part
um but don't don't read them through a
communitarian lens because that that's
other people like ezioni and you know
people who are committed to that
uh the banyan what do you think about
the vaccine mandates going on i think we
should have more of them i think i think
if this were you know
it's really weird the way things have
become politicized
particularly here in america
if we were living in the reagan era you
can bet your ass that every single
republican would be for vaccine mandates
it's only because we've got this toxic
mix
of you know
more freedom types freedom without any
sort of responsibility
and the you know sheer oppositionalism
of so many conservatives who aren't
really conservatives at all these days
that we've got and and all the kooky
conspiracy theory [ __ ] that came
through
if if we were back in the reagan era or
even in the early bush era you can bet
that republicans and democrats would
have lined up together and we would have
vaccine mandates and we would have had
mass mandates and social distancing
mandates
and covid would have been more or less
on its way out by now instead we have
all these [ __ ] all over the place
who are
you know either deluded or on the grift
because they're they're vaccinated but
they're preaching not getting vaccinated
all these people with these these weird
ideas about what freedom really consists
in
and they put everybody else at risk you
know
um so you know what do i think about
vaccine mandates
uh if you don't like it suck it up you
know if your job requires you that you
get vaccinated now you've gotta now
you've got a problem right um you gotta
make a decision and uh just like any
other thing when i used to teach in the
prisons i had to get tested for
tuberculosis every year
and if i had tuberculosis i wouldn't be
able to go teach in the prison it'd be
tough [ __ ] right because we don't want
to get people sick
when sars the first sars
broke out we were you know doing some
pretty draconian stuff in the prison to
keep people from getting sick you know
we stopped shaking hands we sanitize
things as much as possible these are
rational ways of behaving in relation to
pandemics and there's always going to be
some [ __ ] who don't you know
who want to do their own thing
um but
you know it's a question of how many we
have and and what we're able to actually
do
so
there's my there's my point of view on
that probably some people aren't going
to like it but
too bad right
uh theo telos love the amas do you like
any ecological thinkers you you could
suggest uh more practically do you have
any recommendations for writing for
journals for the first time in grad
school
um so two different questions writing
for journals in grad school
yeah there's this big push like oh
you've got to have published three
articles or we're not going to consider
you for jobs or stuff like that
so for the first thing i'm going to tell
you is that
there is no such thing as a top tier
journal
there's there's no consensus in the
field of philosophy about what the best
journals are there is local consensus so
like among analytic philosophers you
know they'll say these are the really
good journals but go and ask some other
philosophers and they'll be like well
those are okay but you know these are
better you know um there there's
people will try to tell you all sorts of
[ __ ] about this sort of stuff don't
don't believe them just localize it say
well i guess for that kind of person
this is a top-tier journal
um
do you need to publish stuff
sure publish it in grad school journals
you know
there plenty of them exist it's a good
way to like get your feet wet and get an
idea about what's going on i'm volunteer
to be on the staff of journals it's a
great way to see how the sausage is made
uh behind the scenes which may sicken
you or you might actually become
fascinated with it i'll tell you this
you know double blind review very often
is not double blind review i can tell
you that from from experience
um
and you know you can send stuff out you
want to prepare for a lot of rejection
uh and it'll be arbitrary rejection
that's probably what hurts the most is
you know the proverbial reviewer number
two who's just kind of a jerk and
looking to
to find reasons to to not publish
something by the way editors will
sometimes say find a reason not to
publish this this article and they'll
find a reviewer to do it or find give me
a good review for this
now back to ecological thinkers uh yeah
my fellow wisconsinite aldo leopold
um
[Music]
he's he's a guy who came up with
something called the land ethic which i
think is a lot less extreme than like
deep ecology which to me seems
completely unworkable um for our our
contemporary world although leopold was
a great writer and thinker who was based
here
in wisconsin um
and i you know started with san coney
almanac
that's a good one we read that when i
was in in college as part of our
our american studies honors course and
i'm so glad that i did encounter leopold
so
all right um
dylan what would be a good intro to
gender theory depends on what you mean
by gender theory i mean if you're
talking about thinking about gender in
general and
you're wanting to go at it through like
a equality lens mary wallstone crafts
vindication of the rights of women is
probably the place to start uh
majorly important work for for feminism
as a whole
and looking at the
gender relations of her time and what
was what was rational it was irrational
in those um
but i mean you can go all the way back
to thinking about plato's republic and
his his insistence that
women should actually be part of the
armed forces
because some of them are thematic and a
lot of men are not you know
um
so i don't know uh
i don't really do a lot of introductory
stuff
fatal remains in your experience how
does virtue ethic stoicism change the
way you phase phrase or approach ethical
questions and dilemmas as opposed to
other liberal schools of thought as in
male human law human law well i mean
i don't i don't like
have a schema and i don't think a lot of
people have schemas unless they're you
know kind of asking for trouble where
they approach situations and they say
let me apply my liberal million you know
uh
spectacles to this
um you know the way philosophical works
work on us is by
making us think about things
and sometimes there's practices that we
do and they help us they're like
conversation partners and figuring out
how do i unfuck myself and make myself
less of a screwed up person
and how do i move myself towards some
sort of goods and how do i handle things
i'll point out too that mill if you read
mill
says that the utilitarianism that he is
developing
is you know taking the epicurean
tradition further but also adding some
christian and stoic elements to it right
so it's not so cut and dried as you've
got you know
um this over here and this over here
these people are all you know uh
connected with each other
uh venner do i believe mind uploading
mind copying is possible on
philosophical grounds um
i don't know what that means
are you asking do i think it's
ever going to be possible because it's
definitely not possible now i mean
we still don't know
what the connection between the brain
and the mind is even though people will
tell you that they've got it all figured
out they don't
um
you know we know that this this wet wear
that we've got in here is is important
in many ways but can we actually map out
you know how all the neurons are
connected with each other no we're no
we're remotely close to that i don't
know that we ever will truly be
for a given human being
let's say we could do that though and we
had like the total brain map at a
particular point in time so this is
we're doing sci-fi here more than
anything else
could that um
could that be the consciousness of the
person yeah maybe or it could be a
conscious thing that is is still not yet
the person
um we don't really know you know
all right uh
a domes not a question but i've been
subscribed to you since my first ba i've
been looking at your content at times
now i'm doing a phd in philosophy time
flies oh congratulations that's great uh
and that is indeed some time right if
you did a va
and then either did an m.a and now doing
the phd or you jumped right into a phd
program that's uh that's quite cool
um
very nice
telly the therapist is the new priest at
least according to philip reef i guess
if you buy philip reef then i guess you
buy that that point of view
i avoid those sort of sound bites myself
but you know
sam constant tips for reading more
philosophy i've got a billion books i
want to read on my shelves but they take
so much work to get into i don't read
nearly as much as i'd like so i mean the
simple answer is
keep reading more right but but how do
you do that there's there's a legitimate
question there you get you get
discouraged
because you're like oh [ __ ] i've got all
these books that i bought
how am i going to get to all of this
that's a good that is a legitimate
question and the answer is you probably
won't
and you're never going to
you're never going to read everything
all you got to do is walk into a
you know significant library and look
around just at the philosophy section
and you can be like
yeah this is a lot i i'm not going to
read most of this and most of what i
read i'm probably not going to retain
100
so
what do i make of that well you read
what you you can right and try to and
you don't have to rush yourself
um just read it thoughtfully
be ready to reread
um
and that's okay
you might consider getting if you if you
find yourself
five years down the line and a lot of
those books that you bought you never
cracked open you can ask yourself am i
honestly ever going to read these books
and if not you know
set them free go sell them to a used
bookstore or give them to somebody else
or something like that
alex i was wondering what you think
about jordan peterson do you think he's
actually got something valuable to say
or he's full of crap
um
so i i get you know i used to get
peterson questions all the time back uh
in the day
and i've always thought that peterson is
just
essentially a grifter who
who became popular through political
opposition to things became a darling of
the right and i've said many times that
he became a victim of his own success
because he started
maybe maybe he already did believe his
own [ __ ] in the past but um he
definitely started believing it once he
became a celebrity and that's very
dangerous for for you know any any
thinker uh for that to happen um yeah as
chest off talks about it they become a
prophet right and a prophet is not a
good word for for shasta
i would say this as i would say about so
many other um people who are very
popular but are really third rate when
it comes to their their philosophy
what there is of it
anything that's good in them you can get
somewhere else without all the
entailments and entanglements
if you need jordan peterson to tell you
to clean your room and to start like
thinking about your life
you got bigger problems than whether you
should be
you know paying attention to peterson
because i mean
it's not it's not
you don't even need a philosopher to
tell you keep your room clean right
put some order into your life
and it sure as hell doesn't have to come
with all this you know
weird
dominance hierarchy crap and all the
misogyny and you know
bad reads of of things and relying on
terrible
uh understandings of post-modernism and
blurring that together with marxism you
don't have to buy into all that stuff um
i don't know why anybody would want to
waste their time with peterson when they
could be spending it reading aristotle
or you know if you're attracted to the
people that peterson talks about why
take peterson's word about dostoyevsky
read dostoevsky right
um so you know that's that's my answer
about peterson
and it's the same answer that i'd give
about like sam harris or any of these
other
uh people that we we put forward william
lane craig you know
in the religious field
um don't waste your time with them you
know you got limited time read read good
philosophy instead
um
and now there's one other thing oh
they're the gateway person because of
them i started studying this and that
you don't need them then quit talking
about them they're they're not important
in the long run they're going to be
footnotes
later on down the line and we're still
going to be reading some other people
who really do matter whose thought is
worth worth spending time with
uh jordan says what would you say is the
difference between p the way people
process linguistic negation in
day-to-day life and in the philosophical
life
i don't know
i mean is is there a way that people in
general process linguistic negation in
the philosophical life i don't think so
um
i i don't know what that that uh
what that means so i i can't really
answer that
habit please keep this live because i
need captions to get understanding
everything thank you okay so keep it
live i guess you mean don't don't uh
delete it yeah that's that's fine i can
do that
um
jeff sullivan i'm lately lately
interested in nominalism any thoughts on
it who are the major thinkers
obviously william of ockham
i mean before that you have somebody who
anselm attacked uh rosslyn right
nominalism was making its way into
western thought in in around the uh
11th and 12th century
um but you know you get a more
nominalistic turn with
modern thinkers although they're not
often framing it as being part of the
nominalist tradition or something like
that but i mean
hobbs would kind of fit in there
wouldn't he right
um if you look at what barkley is doing
with
with his his stuff um
in in his principles i guess you could
say there's a nominalism there
but
you know and and we go all the way you
know we mentioned to lose duluz is
interested in the nominalist stuff
but it's not as if there's like a
coherent nominalist tradition as far as
i've ever seen
all right um
chris thoughts on the elimination of
tenure in georgia
so
i don't know that tenure has been
eliminated in georgia are you talking
about specific cases because that's all
i've seen i haven't seen tenure
completely go away
just in the state universities
uh let alone across all the private
universities in georgia
um but i you know i went on a little bit
of a rant earlier
i frankly don't give a [ __ ] about tenure
you know because
so few of us have even the
opportunity to earn it i mean i had the
opportunity to go for early tenure and
promotion
when i was working at fayetteville state
university and the process was i was
going to get through it but the process
was really stupid and
poorly organized you had to go through
like seven different
committees or or offices to get it and
then you know post tenure review i think
a lot of people are very confused about
what tenure means and who actually
possesses it
very few academics
um
or instructors in the united states
these days are in tenure track
lines
most
much more often you're an adjunct and
you have zero
uh protection and zero
um
you know
what what you could call um
job security or you're in a temporary
line like maybe of a two-year contract
uh the entire time that i worked at
indiana state prison in my first job i
was not tenured track even though i was
reappointed every single year
and that meant that i i could be my job
could be phased out at any time which it
was even if you have tenure um the
school can engage in some monkey
business
and
get rid of your major your program like
they did at carthage college i saw
15 of my colleagues who had tenure
get fired
because the school phased out their
their programs including the philosophy
program i saw the guy who was in charge
of philosophy and his wife both get
fired with a month's notice
and then get rehired back as adjuncts no
benefits no job security they've
subsequently moved on
does tenure mean that much
it used to mean something
um
i think those of us who
aren't in tenured positions probably
don't need to care about it
you know uh it was up to the tenured
professors
and those on tenure track to protect it
and to protect all of their
much more precarious colleagues
and they didn't
you know so
i don't really uh
i don't really care about it quite
frankly
uh naive any recommendation about
loyalty about the you know issue of
loyalty besides uh josiah royce's view
josiah rice for those who don't know
wrote an entire book about loyalty
uh yeah gabriel marcel gabriel marcel by
the way was a big fan of royce
uh marcel
talks about it quite a bit so i would i
would you know think about his works
um
[Music]
loyalty is a is an issue that comes up
in business ethics do we have a loyalty
to the firm to customers um and so it's
kind of an there's a like a literature
out there about that as well
aiden what do you think of alexander
kojev's reading of hegel alexander
kojev's reading of hegel is definitely
more kojev than hegel
which is often the case with you know
important thinkers i'd say the same is
true of heidegger's reading of hegel
what there is of it
which you can find in parts of being in
time and then of course his lectures on
hegel's phenomenology which is
unfortunately very short
kojov is interesting you know he's worth
reading for his own sake i'd say
um i wouldn't rely on him as a faithful
interpreter of hegel
but he's he's you know he's an
interesting guy
so
his lectures on uh you know um
introduction to the the reading of hegel
is is uh
insightful i'd say so
um
as a matter of law as a law student i
can say philosophy appears in law often
but how do law and philosophy relate i
think law is the application of
philosophy your thoughts
i'd say you know it's much more complex
than that um
yeah
you know there's there's a whole thing
called philosophy of law right an entire
discipline
and there's a you know it's a good
reading so depending on what law school
you're going to some of them kind of
slough off on this but um you know
they'll recommend reading aristotle's
rhetoric or things like that
so it you know that's
there's a lot of complex
interconnections between philosophy and
law i wouldn't say that law is just an
application of philosophy
um
john holloway are there any metal bands
you wish you could have seen that are no
longer around we know you love dia who
else yeah dio is
if there's one
band
that i would most have loved to get to
see that i didn't get to see it was dio
um
you know it's it's cool because i i mean
i i didn't get to see like the original
version of a lot of bands
like uriah heap for example but i got to
see uriah heat
a couple years back here in milwaukee
actually my wife got a a cameo
from the um lead singer when i was
getting down
uh sending a personal message to me
which was kind of nice
so
yeah who else i mean
i never got to see twisted sister and i
i heard they were really a great
band live
that would have been fun
um
i would have liked to have seen more of
motorhead i only saw them once with mega
death
and they did like a seven song set
um and that was back in the
uh mid
uh 2010s
and i think lemmy was probably already
getting getting sick by that
um
[Music]
riot i would have loved to have seen the
original riot not quiet riot riot the
band from new york
um
with guys faranza as the vocalist
they are a really really underrated band
their first three albums are amazing
stuff
starting with rock city then narita and
then um
blanking on the third album uh you can
look it up
um
girls school you know i mean there's
still an opportunity to see girls school
because they're still alive
thank god but i haven't seen them and i
think i would have really loved to see
them back in the day
um
[Music]
i mean i've seen metallica and megadeth
maybe old anthrax would have been cool
um
[Music]
but you know i've seen a lot of the
bands that i want to see
and i saw them you know
saw a lot of them when they were really
good too
um like you know i've seen kiss now
three times in my life i don't think i'd
want to see him again because i hear
paul stanley's voice is giving out and
you know kiss shows are always fun but
do i need to see them again
um
maybe not
yeah that's that's a tough one um that
could actually be a good article
sometime to write oh i know who i would
have loved to have seen
tank
yeah with algae ward
that would that would have been pretty
awesome
all right philosophical life
if you had to rate the rank the greatest
philosophers of all time who would be
your top five and whatever i don't know
i i don't have favorites and greatest of
all time or stuff like that so i'm not a
good person to answer that sort of thing
yerry duranga what drew what has drawn
you more to the catholic tradition as
opposed to the eastern orthodox well
neither one is a tradition there are
traditions tied together in incredibly
complex ways there's a considerable
overlap i was raised catholic you know
and a lot of the people that i studied
were in the catholic intellectual
tradition and i see no reason to leave
it to go further east i mean the church
is a mess but it's always been a mess if
you know your church history and the
eastern orthodox churches are just as
much of a mess in many different ways
i will say that the right that i
probably enjoyed the most was
the maronite right where where the
liturgy was partly in syriac and arabic
as well as english and a lot of the
singing was was quite good and we had
very old liturgy
um
but you know
you just kind of muddle through it's
these sort of things are at such a high
level of abstraction
that i don't think that they're
particularly
uh
important to worry about unless you find
yourself having a crisis of faith or
something like that right
professor murdoch where can i find that
podcast about stoicism and marriage
well you know like i said we're going to
be doing it massimo pigliucci has a
podcast um you just type it into google
and
um
mo's podcast will come up i think he
does it with rob coulter right from
wyoming
and you can also find one that andy and
i did with catherine coramillis
and you just type her name in catherine
cora
and type in you know sadler and marriage
and
it should come up right
so
sam says i want to take a stab at
hagel's phenomenology as much by myself
as possible before diving into your
lectures do you have any advice on how
to step into that
i mean
uh read it all the way through
that
you know
see see how it works for you um you're
probably going to find
that you know as most people do hegel is
difficult to read and understand and
that's okay
and uh you'll inevitably get pretty
bogged down around force and the
understanding because that's the most
difficult part of the work
um
you don't have to use my lectures you
can use all sorts of other commentaries
if you want to
you know there's hip elites
i mean you can read kojev if you want to
stanley rosen has a book you know
there's there's multiple translations
out there you can compare them against
each other
but it's going to be a slog i don't know
why you want to start with the
phenomenology anyway the the places to
start with hegel i think and i say this
over and over again are with his
lectures on the philosophy of history
and his lectures on the history of
philosophy i i don't think people
should try to tackle the phenomenology
as their first book any more than people
people are always like you know i want
to read con first critique and what did
kant himself prescribe before reading
the first critique the prologue not to
any future metaphysics read that you
know that's his introductory work into
that
um
there it's weird people have like these
these big books that they've got to read
you know and
until you've actually like spent some
time in them you don't know
whether it's worthwhile for you or not
not everybody has to read hagel's
phenomenology not everybody has to read
spinoza's ethics not everybody has to
read plato's republic you know
um there's there's different different
things for different people you know
mike ron trying to go through lacon's
work having difficulties understanding
any tips for understanding the khan any
secondary resources you know that i'm
i'm not a big secondary resources guy
so i won't make any recommendations that
way i will say
if you want to read lacan and you want
stuff that's easier to understand than
the accrete read his seminars which are
also difficult but he sort of like with
hegel right the lectures on stuff
easier than the phenomenology
lacan seminars are him teaching to
people it's easier than those
stand-alone
uh
or writings um
the other thing to keep in mind is laka
in his writings is showing off to the
french
psychoanalytic establishment how smart
he is and he's being kind of a
obscurantist jerk
so don't let it get to you that stuff is
hard to wrap your head around right
um
edip would you consider doing a series
on islamic philosophy um covering people
like al kindy for robbie abbott sena
i've i've answered this before probably
not because i don't read arabic you know
why not have some somebody who's an
expert in that you know marquette over
there has an entire thing called aquinas
in the arabs project you know run by
richard taylor look it up on google you
know ask one of those people to put
together videos because you know they're
better suited for it we should all stick
to
our particular wheel wells we should
stay in our lanes so happens that you
know i have a lot of lanes but
uh the philosophy of the islamic world
is not one of them any more than
you know aztec philosophy is you know or
um
[Music]
you know
stuff that i i can't read the original
languages like you know talking about
various schools of buddhism where i i
don't read classical chinese or poly or
any of these these sorts of things you
know
um i i think that
we want to spread the work around as
much as possible right
uh trevor what's the closest political
descriptor you would use for yourself
communist leftist anarchist liberal
virtue ethicist which means that i'm not
going to fit very well
in with anybody
um you know i'm gonna be more opposed to
some things than than others
but you know like aristotle says in the
politics
um there are the you know these
different factions and then there's
those who
strive for virtue and they are a
different class
so so we have to work with others
um
luke asks have i read any of yukio
mishima's work i have not so
overkiller from a philosophical
perspective can you argue that time
travel is possible no because i don't
know the
physics well enough to
comment on that
i'll say that it's kind of you know kind
of
fun for you know thinking about things
in science fiction but
um it's probably not possible so
kirby you sometimes comment that even
though you don't personally get much out
of a thinker
you're happy others see value in them
how might somebody cultivate that
attitude that's a good question i don't
know how how you cultivate that attitude
um
maybe not working on it directly but
working on other stuff
if you have a kind of professional
jealousy
where you want everybody to
think that the stuff that you are
interested in is important and the stuff
you're not interested in isn't
that's going to be an impediment to that
right
the more that you can appreciate
other people's points of view
as you know the points of view of other
actual
people who matter
the better off you're you're gonna be
so there's there's probably no one
direct way to cultivate that attitude
but it's probably a result i would guess
of like
becoming more and more
substantively respectful of other
people of human diversity
and it doesn't require that you like say
oh everybody is equally good
everything's wonderful you know you can
say you know some some things are crap
and some things are better
um why are you wasting your time with
crap when you could be spending your
time on better stuff right
but
yeah i mean like
i i like david hume
i i'm not a human by any means i enjoy
reading his writings
and there are people who do work on him
and i i wouldn't you know say like oh
you're wasting your time working on this
guy who i disagree with
um
but
that's that's not going to like draw me
into work
human any substantive way right
all right um
luke uh i've seen some of your lectures
on foucault you point out some of his
errors or where you think he gets some
things wrong what are your thoughts on
foucault as a whole
um
i think that foucault is probably
somebody who's going to be read 100
years from now he won't be read in the
same way
people have gotten a lot of mileage out
of his his work and his approaches
i kind of think that when he's talking
about ancient philosophy he's
he's he's very selective and you
shouldn't you know you can derive
insights from him but don't believe his
stories
um
because they're kind of kind of
self-serving
um
[Music]
and and i think like in the order of
things
he tries to say you know he's not a
structuralist he's doing structuralist
work there
um so you know foucault is every once in
a while kind of cagey but
i think that he's he's an interesting
thinker i mean it turns out now we know
because of the revelations that he was
he was like an absolute scumbag and
pedophile
and that's that's gross and
uh
terrible right
but um
we don't we don't automatically throw
out thought just because somebody's a
dirtbag
so
yeah i mean his work as a whole he made
some interesting and important
contributions it's it's kind of
unfortunate that he
deliberately cut his life short um
[Music]
because he had a lot of interesting
things to say
so yeah that's i think that's about
enough about foucault
oh here's a really interesting question
from giga chad mesh what are your views
on independent scholar outside of the
academy
is there a degree of leg room there
compared to the usual route for academic
writing so there is no usual route for
academic writing
um you want to you know there is an a
academy or anything like that right
there's there's a lot of different ways
in which people
do work inside of the academy and one
institution varies from another but
uh you can say that on the whole there's
a lot of people within the academy
whether they have to be this way or not
who are very preoccupied with like i
gotta get my my articles so i can retain
tenure you know or get tenure or
something like that
and and you notice that there's like i
said there's less and less tenure track
jobs available
[Music]
yeah as an independent scholar
you wind up being
more free in some ways but you're also
handicapped in some ways right so
if you want to try to apply for grants
or stuff like that to support your work
or like support travel it's tougher to
get it as an independent scholar than as
somebody with an academic affiliation
should it be that way probably not right
but life isn't fair
another thing that's really key so i'm
going to point you know once again
marquette is over that way 12 12 blocks
um i'm effectively an independent
scholar although i do you know
hold
uh a academic position at milwaukee
institute of art design
but as far as marquette is concerned i'm
i'm an independent scholar
who every year applies for a
courtesy appointment um in order to be
able to access their research library
and that means not just being able to
get books
but to be able to access a wider range
of articles in jstor stuff like that
and that that's very important for my
ongoing research into like ancient
philosophy
you know
um as well as um getting articles from
my my academic classes that i teach at
mayan you know without the access to
marquette's library i wouldn't have a
lot of the stuff that i have for my
students for the earth c class
so you know
um in some respects
being a independent scholar is good but
it also means you got to find ways to be
able to be a scholar right to get your
hands on the stuff that you want so
there are ways to do it but um
you know
all right professor murdock how do you
feel about ryan holiday i you know i
i've met ryan holiday and interacted
with him
um
i'm not i'm not a big fan of of his his
works
um i think if they're a gateway for
people to get into actually studying
stoicism that's great otherwise
you know i see it as
you know kind of uh
what would you call it you know it's
watered down um and i think a lot of the
you know selling challenge coins and
stuff like that i think that's just this
that's just [ __ ] um i don't think
those serve any useful purpose
for anybody i know all the
justifications people give oh they help
me to remind myself every day well you
could remind yourself just as well tying
a string around your finger you don't
need to show off with that sort of thing
you know we actually have because we got
a copy of it the daily stoic with
stephen hanselman and ryan holiday and
my wife and i were you know we were like
well let's work our way through it
and
we abandoned doing that about
april in part because you know we'd read
the the passage by seneca or marcus
aurelius or whoever and then we'd read
the description after it and we'd be
like
passage was a great reminder
today's is you know not a banger you
know um and then my my wife is still
reading her way through it but she just
reads the actual stoic passage not the
explanation or commentary so i'm you
know not not a huge fan
um
[Music]
had a few interactions and that's it you
know
so
all right um
david mondero thoughts on lonergan
particularly his book insight i'll say
this
lonerganians are really committed to
lonergan
i
started reading some lawn again i never
started reading insight because i wasn't
interested in that particular work i was
looking more at the
stuff about the will
and
i i just
didn't find him to be worth the time
investment for me to
commit to reading them when they had so
many other things to read so there is a
lonergan conference that takes place at
marquette um every uh
every uh
year which is kind of cool so that's
nice
uh elijah says want to thank you so much
for what you do i've been greatly
enjoying your series on hegel look
forward to diving into your other
content oh that's great yeah oh and
elijah is uh
if i'm not mixing him up with somebody
else he's somebody who came to my
attention because he
um
he commented he'd done a video where
he's like commenting on my
hegel video which is really you know
good um
smart way to do things actually uh sort
of explaining what he's getting out of
it and youtube flagged it as like you
know copyright violation so i wrote him
back and i was like this isn't a
copyright violation don't worry about
that do as many as you want to and we
had a nice back and forth interaction
about that so that that's cool
um
[Music]
all right let's see oh just
skipped a bit let me let me scroll back
up and see where we are
um
oh
here's a good question from uh sana
do you feel like you've sacrificed
important aspects of your life for your
job if you do you mind sharing a bit
genuinely what are some pieces of pieces
of advice for philosophy majors even
very personal advice
yeah i'm sure i'm i i've sacrificed uh
things in my life for my job i mean one
of the things
early on you know when i used to try to
apply for academic positions
you
you know it used to be there was like a
season
for applying like jobs for philosophers
would come out and start looking through
them
and you'd start thinking about well
where am i willing to move to you know
do i really want to uproot my family and
go somewhere else
and
you know when i when i took the job at
fayetteville state university i left my
at that time wife uh subsequently
divorced her and my my two kids living
in the house that i had bought from my
my family which was on my family's land
in northwestern indiana
and i looked at it sort of like being on
military deployment you know you you go
down to some other place
you get to see your
you know family every so often you call
on the phone and all that
that was tough you know
um
even before the divorce
um that was tough only getting to see my
kids on holidays and stuff like that
because i was working somewhere else and
i didn't want to uproot them and take
them some other place you know and then
applying for the jobs
it would take so much friggin time and
work and it cost you money too i mean
every time you'd send your letters or
recommendation out it's really kind of a
racket
um it would cost you money and you had
to like mail these things off
you know going to conferences writing
papers for that i'm sure i
i
i was pretty good with my kids about
spending a lot of time with them
um the prison job one of the the few
perks of it
was that i only had to be up there two
days a week
they were very very long days like
sun up to you know deep into the night
sundown but
um
i was able to spend a lot of time with
my my kids during those those uh six
years
um but a lot of academics aren't you
know and i i know a lot of people who
moved all over the place some some never
got a permanent position
they'd move every two years
that is that is difficult you know it
takes a takes a toll on relationships so
um
[Music]
advice about that i mean i i don't know
i think you have to really weigh
what
what it's worth
i mean studying philosophy
at least if you study the right kind of
philosophy
it can really improve your life and your
relationships and and your connections
with other people but
yeah it can it can require a lot
uh maury corey i've been reading a lot
of object oriented ontology from tristan
garcia graham harmon quentin melissou
have you read any of this material and
think they provide a useful framework i
mean i've met graham harmon and
interacted with him
i don't i didn't find the stuff that
he's doing particularly
interesting you know i mean i mean it's
mildly interesting but i just i didn't
find this to be the great revolution
that people are thinking it is but maybe
i'm missing on something
um
even says
what has been the language that for you
was the most difficult to learn and what
was the most fun to learn well the most
difficult is the one that i didn't
actually learn but i've turned my my
hand to a number of times but never
followed through on sufficiently and
that would be chinese
mandarin of course you know as far as
the tone structure but you know written
chinese is the same across the different
uh dialects and maybe i'll do it someday
you know my dad actually
um he he when he was in the army he got
sent to the foreign language school and
he was supposed to learn mandarin and he
was learning it
and uh then the army realized that
they'd never properly
arranged his paperwork and they they
took him out gave him an honorable
discharge and sent him home and he
became a cop
but he's learning he's learning chinese
now and i i said this would be the year
that we'd finally both buckled down and
do it and i haven't done it
so you know the most difficult one is
the one that you don't actually
accomplish i'd say
um
what was the most fun
um i mean french you know i mean i i
grew up learning some french just
because my mom
and her family are francophone
but they speak a kind of hillbilly
french uh it's not quite you know
canadian french uh it's kind of a weird
mishmash of things
and um
you know i grew up like learning all the
swear words from my uncles
then i i you know took a few
i had to take french in in eighth grade
and in tenth grade but i i screwed off
most of the time and just coasted on
what i knew and then when i was in
college i i was thrown into this french
house with a uh we had a native speaker
and then some other people who were
supposed to like be learning french and
i i started to buckle down and learn and
talk with people and then
you know i
i realized i could start reading cool
stuff in french and that was a lot of
fun
you know when my mom went to paris when
i was in grad school
she brought back with her
a big uh robe dictionary
uh which is
it's up in my study i still use it now
uh dairy does do like gramatology
um what else there was uh leibniz's uh
discord
metaphysique
and
um there was something out oh yeah so
series
general you know and i'd read my way
through them and i really enjoyed that i
also would go to like you know the
french table and
chit chat with people i even hooked up
with a a
french grad student for a little while
you know
uh dated her for a bit and uh had some
fun uh and then you know i could talk
with my relatives it was very handy as
my as the older generation was dying off
because some of them as they were going
uh senile
stopped speaking english and could only
speak and understand french um so that
was you know
probably my favorite one
columbus why did adorno hate jazz i
think he saw it as bourgeois you know
um
france franco says how do you keep
reading philosophy books without
entering an echo chamber of a specific
philosophy idea
you just don't enter that echo chamber i
mean
just because it's in a book doesn't mean
that you can only think that way
right um you can you can read and and
you can
keep you know uh a certain distance from
it if you want to
uh mario says is sartre and
existentialism still considered current
or is it posse it was considered passe
when i was entering grad school
because i was at that time kind of a
sartre and existentialist and people are
like are you serious this is the the mid
90s that stuff is dead as a doornail but
i think it comes back in waves you know
i actually had a colleague when i was at
fayetteville state university michelle
darnell who has subsequently moved on to
two other jobs
and she had done her dissertation on
sartre and she was
kind of an existentialist
all right
let me
pick a couple others
um
sort of pluck them out here because
we're getting close to the end of the
the time
um
edward is asking a question that i don't
really have
a good answer to but it's a good
question how would one go about opening
up further philosophical understanding
among the general public in a measured
way that would not cause chaos but bring
enlightenment i mean i guess the only
thing to say is the way that we're
already doing it so many of us in the
field where we do popular talks and we
hold things like
stoicon or the stoic week that by the
way is starting monday you can sign up
for it it's a free course right um
[Music]
if you you know just type in stoic week
2021 and it'll come up there's also
stoic week for students by the way that
you can participate in this year
you know um
doing things like i do with my radio
show
along with my co-host dan
um you know wisdom for life
writing columns you know
uh getting involved in local government
and and talking with people you know um
doing the kind of stuff that i do
executive coaching
ethics consulting you know all of those
are ways of bringing
bringing philosophy to the non-academic
public
and hopefully they don't cause chaos
right uh i don't know if they bring
about enlightenment so much that's
that's a bit of a tougher thing to do
but
all right
um let's see here so
wavy has a question about
uh martial arts
fitness
being from a martial arts fitness
background you have any thoughts on the
connection between philosophy and
fitness
i'm not really from a background as such
i mean i
i learned martial arts when i was
younger
but i haven't kept up with it
but uh fitness
i mean you've got a body
um
you know you should probably try to keep
it in decent shape
and there's no one single way of doing
fitness i mean we all have different
kinds of bodies different things we're
interested in
i enjoy doing the weight circuit you
know and i like doing these long walks
through my city of milwaukee and you
know my wife uh invited me to go to aqua
zumba with her and i'm not really into
that i don't like i don't like doing
classes
if i'm in the pool i just want to like
you know do what i want to do in the
pool not have somebody else tell me what
to do but i i enjoyed zumba when i when
i did it back uh years ago before i
screwed up my knee um
and uh you know i think you have to find
what sort of fitness things work for you
and make you
make you feel better right
you the body is not the be all and end
all of stuff and a lot of people get way
too worried about body image
um you know as it turns out
uh
you know
your body doesn't have to be
particularly good looking in order to to
get you around and you know
not feel bad and
you can use it to to do the things that
you want to do with other people and
whether it's in terms of playing sports
or you know
uh having romantic relationships or
hooking up or stuff like that without it
being you know super attractive um
but you have to you have to be willing
to put in the time right and i mean one
of the thing that's cool about the gym
that i go to is
people walk in and we're all different
ages and we're all different you know
weights and
levels and stuff like that and nobody
gives you a hard time you want to find a
gym like that where people are not going
to give you a hard time about anything
and then you don't give anybody a hard
time right
um
you see somebody who's coming in and
clearly they've been out of the gym for
a long time because they're overweight
and having trouble with the stuff you
smile at them you don't you don't have
to like you know give him a atta boy or
something like that but you know you
just treat him like a human being
um
so that's probably enough about exercise
um
all right skipped again uh there's a
question the
recent question uh are the bucks going
to win another chip this season
i don't know i'm not a bookie i don't do
i don't figure odds about about teams
the bucks are local uh basketball team
they won the nba title this year which
is kind of nice so
um
darth vader will you ever discuss
philosophy with the g-shack that would
be up to g-jack right i doubt that i'm
on his radar i often get people
who are like why don't you have a
collaboration with so-and-so and you're
like how the hell would that happen you
know uh if you want that to be the case
you got to like suggest it to them or
not to them so they're people because uh
you you know you might look at me and be
like oh that guy's got you know 100 000
subscribers on youtube that's nothing
compared to the people who are our big
names right
um
oh here's a good question joel barnett
do you think we will still be talking
about analytic and continental
philosophy in 50 to 100 years
yes
as historians of philosophy the way that
we talk about empiricists and
rationalists now
i don't think that that you know we're
gonna have these dividers at at that
time
and uh in a way thank god for that
because
you know continental philosophy is just
a pale image of what actually
european philosophy is and analytic
philosophy has gotten itself to the
point where it's a it's a victim of its
own success
and analytics first started talking
about being post-analytic 20 years ago
so
no i think that's
that's uh good
um
let's see if we have any other
cool things i can go out on um
[Music]
so here's an interesting one gabriel
says what are your thoughts on the iliad
how important is it to aristotle and
philosophy in general zero importance i
mean
you don't need to read the iliad to
understand aristotle but how important
is the iliad that's a great work of
literature it's an epic
it's worth reading you know
just as much as the odyssey and
just as much as the other great national
epics like the enid or um you know uh
the lucid dads for the portuguese or you
know we could go down the line right
song roland it's worth reading all of
these all these great works are worth
checking out
um
aristotle famously
you know annotated the iliad for
alexander the great and we don't know
that much more about what alexander and
aristotle's relationship actually was
but you know the iliad has you know
very few passages showing up in
aristotle's work so i think that can
kind of help you
um
here's another question are you familiar
with bishop baron do you think he
engages in good discussion scholarship
on philosophy theology do you think he's
merely a popular figure like peterson
craig it's it's the latter i mean he
said some really bone-headed things he
and he's he's clearly driven by his his
own particular political ideology so
um you can anything that you can find in
baron that's good you can you can find
somewhere else without the the
commitments i would say
um
i have not been impressed by the things
that i've seen uh sent to to
to me from him or by you know by people
that are interested in him sending it to
me
um
joel do you uh or
ray says any possibility of doing some
analysis of duluth guitar or roland bart
in the future
bart yeah i mean i i was a big fan of
bart for a while um i'm less a fan of
the lose with katari than to lose by
himself i kind of think atari
brings out the uh
the freewheeling less rigorous kind of
kind of person in him and there's enough
people are doing stuff on anti oedipus
or thousand plateaus why why should i do
that sort of thing um i'm more
interested in you know uh stuff from
like the logic of sense or
essays critical and clinical
or you know some of some of dulu's other
works and it's just a matter of like
actually getting to it you know i have i
have way more
stuff to produce content on than i have
time to produce it
right now you know this whole semester i
think those of you who have been
following
know that i've been cranking out lots
and lots of stuff in the speculative
fiction studies on ursula kayla green's
earth seeks i'm teaching a whole course
on it so that takes a lot of time you
know i the last core concept video that
i actually shot was a while ago i think
um so it'll it'll be you know and then i
have to like get prepared for my
classes that are coming in the spring
i'm teaching a medieval philosophy class
so you know more augustine some boethius
i'm probably going to do something on
gregory's moralia and job
some more anselm some bernard declare mo
some ambellard abelard with eloise as
well
uh
hildegard of bingham
who else
actually so i'm doing the class as a
medieval philosophy and thought class
but i'm doing it
pre-franciscan
pre-dominican so no no you know
bonaventure thomas or anything going
forward i'm just doing everything from
like
late antiquity i'm not doing everything
i'm doing doing things from late
antiquity up into the beginning of the
high middle ages with ann selman abelard
and hildegard
and bernard and people like that you
know mostly benedictines um
well i'm going to have them read the
rule of saint benedict too as well but i
probably won't do videos about that
um
so there's that and then i got to do
some more existentialist stuff you know
um
and then then we'll see what we get to
after that
maybe maybe getting around to duluz and
qatari
um
let's see if there's anything else to
go out on as like a high point
um
[Music]
let me scroll up a little bit here
so
ed has a kind of funny one here
would i like to be remembered as the
greatest youtube philosopher in history
um
i mean
you know yes if it's merited
but i don't know that it would be
merited there's
probably
you know other people doing better stuff
in different places
and i don't know what it means to be a
youtube philosopher other than somebody
who's doing philosophy
on youtube and then the other thing to
say is we don't know what this is going
to turn into you know youtube is going
strong now but
is this format really going to be around
20 years from now look at how much
technological change there's been
just in the last
decade
um you know like youtube you know i got
onto youtube about 10 years ago and it
was like you know just kind of like
starting out
it had been around for a while before
that but
it didn't have the importance that it
does now
um
maybe something else is going to replace
it you know i don't know
um
so that that's a good thing to go out at
i i don't know
um thanks everybody i'm gonna take you
out on a little vision of
the city i live in and and love
this is milwaukee
and as i mentioned you see those
steeples
in the distance that is where marquette
is the jesus
church
with the parish run by the jesuits there
one of the last places they actually
still have any power on campus because
they sure aren't running the place
anymore um so thanks everybody for your
questions and comments and i will see
you
next time around and uh
yeah just stay tuned and we've got other
we got other events coming up live
readings as i mentioned stoic week if
you're interested in stoicism at all
type it into google stoic week 2021
they put a lot of work into the new
class
i'm i'm you know i didn't do that much
because i was busy with stoicon but
all right i'll see everybody